GOOD EVENING.
WELCOME TO WASHINGTON.
I'M CHRIS WALLACE AND FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS SENDING THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER WITH MEXICO.
IT'S A DRAMATIC STEP, BUT WHEN
WE HAVE SEEN BEFORE IN RECENT
HISTORY.
CHIEF WHITE HOUSE CORRESPONDENT
JOHN ROBERTS STARTS US OFF
TONIGHT WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION'S LATEST PLAN TO
PROTECT THE BORDER AND TO GET
MORE SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENTS
WALL.
GOOD EVENING, JOHN.
>> CHRIS, GOOD EVENING TO YOU.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS OFTEN BRAGGED
ABOUT A DRAMATIC REDUCTION IN
ACTIVITY AS TO WHAT HAPPENED AT
THE BORDER, LEADING MANY
WONDERING WHAT THE URGENCY IS
RIGHT NOW IT IS ON THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO THE BORDER.
IN THE END, IT MAY BE MORE ABOUT
APPLYING POLITICAL PRESSURE TO
GET CONGRESS TO ACT.
FOR THE THIRD TIME IN RECENT
HISTORY, THE U.S. PRESIDENT WILL
SEND A NATIONAL GUARD TO HELP
SECURE THE SOUTHERN BORDER.
THE SECRETARY OF HOMELAND
SECURITY TODAY MAKING THE
OFFICIAL ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SPEAK OF THE PRESIDENT HAS
DIRECTED THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
DEFENSE AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
HOMELAND SECURITY WORK TOGETHER
WITH OUR GOVERNORS TO DEPLOY THE
NATIONAL GUARD TO OUR SOUTHWEST
BORDER TO ASSIST THE BORDER
PATROL.
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE SIGNING A
PROCLAMATION TO THAT EFFECT
TODAY.
>> THE DEPLOYMENT IS EXPECTED TO
BEGIN ALMOST IMMEDIATELY, AS
SOON AS TONIGHT.
BUT ITS FULL SCOPE IS STILL
BEING WORKED OUT WITH THE
GOVERNORS OF TEXAS, NEW MEXICO,
ARIZONA, AND CALIFORNIA.
WHILE THE NUMBER OF TROOPS IS
UNCLEAR, THE RULES OF ENGAGEMENT
WILL BE SIMILAR TO OPERATION
JUMP START THOUSAND SIX.
>> IN TERMS OF THE OPERATIONS OF
THE NATIONAL GUARD WILL BE
INVOLVED IN, OPERATION
JUMP-START SPECIFICALLY, THE
NATIONAL GUARD, THEY WERE ONLY
IN A SUPPORT CAPACITY TO THE
BORDER PATROL.
THINKING OF SIMILAR RULES OF
ENGAGEMENT?
>> WE ARE WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNORS.
WE HAVE SUPPORT ACTIVITIES THAT
ARE VERY SIMILAR TO JUMP-START.
>> IT WOULDN'T BE ACTUAL
ENFORCEMENT.
>> CORRECT, AS OF NOW.
>> ACCORDING TO SECRETARY
NIELSEN, CALLING UP THE
NATIONAL GUARD REFLECTS
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S FRUSTRATION
WITH CONGRESS FOR WITHHOLDING
MONEY FOR A PART OF ALL AND
REFUSING TO GIVE HIM WHAT HE
WANTS ON IMMIGRATION REFORM.
ARIZONA CONGRESSMAN, AN IRAQ WAR
VETERAN, CALLED THE DEPLOY IN
INSULT TO OUR TROOPS, AND
TWEETED...
THAT BROUGHT A SHARP REACTION
FROM PRESS SECRETARY SARAH
HUCKABEE SANDERS.
>> IF THAT CONGRESSMAN IS SO
CONCERNED, MAYBE HE OUGHT TO
SHOW UP AND ACTUALLY SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THAT WOULD FIX THESE
PROBLEMS INSTEAD OF BLAMING THE
PRESIDENT IS ACTUALLY TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT FOR YOU TO
SPEAK WITH THE WHITE HOUSE ALSO
SOUGHT TODAY TO ALLAY FEARS
OF AN EMINENT PULLOUT FROM
SYRIA, AS PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID
LAST WEEK AND AGAIN
YESTERDAY, HE WANTS TO BRING
U.S. TROOPS HOME FROM SYRIA
SOON.
>> IT'S TIME.
IT'S TIME.
WE WERE VERY SUCCESSFUL AGAINST
ISIS.
WE WILL SUCCESSFUL AGAINST
ANYBODY MILITARY.
BUT SOMETIMES IT'S TIME TO COME
BACK HOME.
>> IN A STATEMENT, THE PRESS
SECRETARY SAID THE UNITED STATES
AND OUR PARTNERS REMAIN
COMMITTED TO ELIMINATING THE
SMALL ISIS PRESENCE IN SYRIA
THAT FORCES HAVE ON ALREADY
ERADICATED.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO CONSULT WITH
THE ALLIES AND FRIENDS REGARDING
FUTURE PLANS.
BUT OFFICIALS STILL FOX NEWS THE
PRESIDENT WANTS U.S. FORCES HOME
AS SOON AS IS PRACTICAL.
LONG-TERM STABILIZATION OF SYRIA
MAY BE LEFT TO ITS NEIGHBORS.
>> THEY ARE THE ONES THAT ARE AT
THE GRADE OF RISK SO THEY SHOULD
BE STEPPING UP AND DOING MORE,
AND THE PRESIDENT IS CALLING
ON OTHER COUNTRIES TO DO JUST
THAT.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE TODAY
DISMISSED CONCERNS ABOUT A
LOOMING WAR, THIS ONE WITH CHINA
OVER TRADE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S NEWLY MINTED
CHIEF ECONOMIC ADVISOR MAKING
HIS FIRST APPEARANCE ON THE
NORTH LAWN.
LARRY KUDLOW SUGGESTING
NEGOTIATIONS MAY AVOID TARIFFS
BEFORE THEY EVER GO INTO EFFECT.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S A TRADE
WAR.
I THINK THERE WILL BE INTENSE
NEGOTIATIONS ON BOTH SIDES.
LOOK, WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE WHOLE
PICTURE, BLAME CHINA, DON'T
BLAME PRESIDENT TRUMP.
TRUMP IS THE SOLUTION.
>> LARRY KUDLOW ACKNOWLEDGE THE
STOCK MARKET IS FLUSH WITH
ANXIETY, VEERING WILDLY ON A
DAILY BASIS.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS SEEMINGLY
UNCONCERNED WITH A MARKET STRAY
RATIONS.
>> WE MAY HAVE A LITTLE BIT
SHORT TERM PAIN BUT THE WILL
HAVE LONG-TERM SUCCESS.
>> LARRY KUDLOW INSISTS THERE IS
A POT OF GOLD AND ECONOMIC
GROWTH WAITING ON THE OTHER END
OF A RECALIBRATION OF THE
U.S.-CHINA TRADE RELATIONSHIP.
THE QUESTION, THOUGH, CHRIS, CAN
THE PRESIDENT TO REACH THE END